on this episode Eugene REM stops by and
talks entrepreneurship catch rumble and
we had a couple of calls that were
[ __ ] legit hey everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk so three oh three of the
askgaryvee show I'm excited you could
tell by my energy couple things that are
exciting me one a couple of my favorite
alumni are back in the building
cuz two very handsome men to work for
another handsome man and he's here
Eugene I'm gonna allow you to introduce
yourself to the audience in a minute
amazing entrepreneur behind some of my
favorite brands in culture right now
catch rumble and other things we'll get
into his origin story in a second
Instagram Facebook you guys are live but
ultimately why I think I'm most pump is
I just tasted empathy rose' for the
first time our master plan is in motion
I'm very excited and this should be a
really good episode so Eugene for the
vaynernation that's listening why don't
you tell them who you are and what and
how you synthesize your origins - how I
how I arrived are you who am I alright
well Gary thanks for having me I
appreciate it
I've never seen such an energetic group
of people in an office before this is
crazy
thank you my name is Eugene Ram a
co-founder of catch hospitality group we
own catch in New York Los Angeles Las
Vegas Playa del Carmen and Lexington
brass also co-founder of rumble boxing
which is here in New York LA DC Philly
and San Francisco with a lot more come
in there and I came here via Russia from
New Jersey which I don't think would be
interesting to any of your viewers
because they wouldn't know where that
was about but came to the states in 1980
and grew up in Bergen County New Jersey
and worked my way to Hofstra University
in the New York City at 22 and starred
in the male below 40 it's really crazy
how similar our backgrounds are yeah
really kind of scary similar it is it
Soviet Union in during a you know have
you by the way did you know how few
people got outdoor
era I googled it okay during
Thanksgiving with my parents it was in
the hundreds of thousands yeah it's nuts
and they were all like homies too they
all like knew each other I feel like
they were all like st. Petersburg and
you did you have family in America I
have some your parents had to have
somebody we had a cousin my cousin and
my my father's sister was here but we
had to stop in Italy for like three four
months or so in Austria for a few weeks
- no I don't think that was not that was
a week I know exactly changed in 80
compared to 78 that's right yes right we
I know I noticed how I love pizza and
pasta because we're right we lived right
above a pizza store so um I remember
that and then we came I don't remember
but I'm told that but it's crazy man
it's crazy and by the way a lot of
successful people coming out of that
little little little little sample of
people's pretty though
but it's also interesting what's
interesting about you and I talked about
it off in it and we've become friendly
in recent years and a lot of it you know
you've been you know I'm super happy to
have you on the show because you
sometimes you'll ping me randomly be
like oh I like that podcast I like that
podcast so super don't we become
friendly kids that I like the lot that
worked at Vayner that like the machine
was [ __ ] up so I'm okay go to hit
like like if there's so much warmth in
here yeah but what's interesting is I
often say like I was unusual because I
was such a bad student when all of our
contemporaries need to because but like
listen Hofstra is way better than Mount
Ida College but it's no [ __ ] Yale no
no no [ __ ] student I was I was a D
student I wasn't see my soon and by the
way there's Hofstra and then there's a
new school at Hofstra where it's like if
you can't get into the regular Hofstra
that's what yeah they scented the new
school I was able to get back up to the
regular Hofstra but let me tell you
smaller classes yeah yeah because the
way people teach you baseball carted out
I thought we talked about was baseball
carted out I was flea marketed out my
father had a SAN selling the Russian
dolls and he gave me 20% of his brush
cos and the M and the amber and all that
all that crap and he gave me 20% of his
table but for me it was it was an
opportunity hanging out with my dad and
it was an opportunities to sell some
stuff and it kept me busy cuz that was
my sport that was that was my sport so
it was like I didn't understand what it
really all meant because my dad couldn't
sew it up for me together but now
looking back on it you like all right
when it was cold and they had a snow day
you go knock on doors and you shovel and
you shovel snow because that's how you
make some cash and all I really money
was freedom period if I got money I
could do things if I got no money my
parents weren't giving it to me so
that's how I connected this whole thing
all the young hustlers on right now make
sure you put your phone numbers and ek
is sitting by the computer ready to take
phone numbers when I do call him pretty
soon so you know here's where our
stories deviate you're much cooler than
me definitely not yes you definitely are
I go liquor store you go into the
nightlife scene as you work yes how did
that all break out real simple moved to
New York I was a bartender in college
and I took a crap job in ad sales hated
my life and I moved to the storage room
out of fashion and celebrity PR firm but
I knew you could wear sweat pants and I
knew you could listen to hip-hop and I
knew that like and that was really it
and I was like well this is must be for
me and I always just walk down the
streets of New York and be like who is
walking around in a t-shirt and jeans at
noon while I'm in this crap suit at this
crap job and I was like this can't be so
really humbling 22 G's a year but I had
bought some houses in college with my
bartending money that we started
flipping so I had enough cash to hold me
over and that's the money I used so I
can live in New York so I started going
out I made my own business card and a
company that had no bit that wouldn't
allow me to make my business cards I
wanted to get into the clubs so I
started doing that they said hey you can
work the door for free at our events on
the weekends if you want and I was like
absolutely and they thought I was nuts
but I wanted the access so I started
meeting people and I did that for about
18 months and then 9/11 hit and then the
you know the PR market just dried cuz
nobody wants to talk about so-and-so
wearing Jimmy Choos after 9/11 and then
I took a job I got lucky I got a job
with Randy and Scott Gerber who owned
the dhobi hotel bars and that was my
first job and I did special events for
them but they let me have a comp account
and on the weekends I could go to my
other friend's places and pay for [ __ ]
or I can go to these places invite
people and not pay for [ __ ] and that's
how it kind of started so how was your
leverage that was my leverage that
my that was my equity that I had with
young contemporaries and you guys could
you could you could in essence entertain
it I could entertain nieces at a place
that didn't have anyone else
entertaining while my friends were
working at the coolest places I wouldn't
say that they were the coolest places on
earth but they were certainly good
enough but the experience that I could
person create for them would be better
and that's how I kind of worked it and
one by one and I worked for Randy and
Scott for two years then a gentleman
named Steve Hanson who's like a G in New
York and if you don't know it was be our
guest he sold it but uh you know he had
20 restaurants and I go to work for him
I'm 25 years old now and I open he
crossed shipped me packing he was at me
he told me what the meat packing was he
said I'm opening up this space in the
Meatpacking this little V I took a
Saturday night off I just walked around
there and I saw all these bars and then
you saw some like you know you saw meat
lockers and then you saw [ __ ] and
drug dealers and you're like well this
must be where it's at if you get a
little bit of everything and I became
the director promotions for his company
and he drove everything he drilled New
York City and he I never met a man I
worked as hard as he did he work 22
hours a day he would he would be able to
respond to my email at the end of the
4:00 a.m. shift and he would start those
emails at like 6 a.m. and he would go he
well he sold he sould be our guest to
Starwood and then Starwood sold it to my
current partner landry so it's come full
circle which is super interesting but
III think you know he bought a hotel and
he buys a building but I think he's I
think he's semi-retired and how old is
he living is I think I don't know I'm
not sure exactly I think he's 60 ish but
um yeah he was a beast and I gotta say
we talk about mentorship allow you talk
about mentorship a lot but I probably
spend a total of 72 hours with him in
two years but I can tell you those 72
hours with that one man said that shaped
everything so it's not about like oh I
work for this guy for two years about
this this is very meta there's a there's
a young man sitting to like two people
behind you who literally go who
literally caught him talk about meta on
meta meta who literally called in on an
askgaryvee type thing but was just by
myself we had this kind of like fun
moment he was great and I just like
liked him and I said come in
and here yes this is the day he came in
and I awesome and I just met with him
before this yeah and I basically told
him to work for Dave East the hip hop
artist every right and this is like my
biggest like I believe in this the most
people are listening right now they're
about to call and put in your phone
number for Eugene we're gonna get to
your calls in a minute
especially the hustlers and what I mean
by hustlers you've been listening to you
know my back story you've been listening
to Eugene's Eugene is like I'm in this
and we don't even know each other well
enough for me to almost paint this
compliment but I'll take it though thank
you you're gonna take it preciate it
there haven't been a lot of people I've
met in the last five years that I that
there's this Delta X and y-axis of me
genuinely liking the human being and me
believing in their actual skillset you
sit on a very again we've only spent
eleven six seven hours together yeah but
it's already there for me so here you
are you're you've been successful by all
accounts I personally believe that
you're about to get really successful
because I think you're patient and
hungry and doing the right things that
even if the global economy takes a step
back I just I can see it yes know
exactly who you're gonna be at 71 and
I'm looking forward to having more
stories with you
so when be around 71 but yes but you're
sitting here and telling everybody the
72 hours
I spent with this person shaped you know
you had your natural DNA the hustler and
then is it fine
I just wish more people heard you and
this is why I'm making the big to-do
here 72 hours now all of you who I tell
in your 20s when you're doing dick [ __ ]
nothing with your [ __ ] life when I
tell you to spend two hours a day on
your couch doing dick [ __ ] nothing and
DM everybody you admire and say to them
I've got [ __ ] time your busiest [ __ ]
I will [ __ ] do anything eat [ __ ]
for 15 hours a week for free for you a
once in a blue moon somebody says yes
yeah
and that will change your life how do
you happen addy rock like happen Andy
this is real but it's funny but people
will pay for college but they don't want
to not get paid to go do work how did
you get your job at Boehner originally
and how long were you here two years
right and then that led to this that's
right which is fitting you perfectly
right like I don't like I just wish
[ __ ] and you how'd you get it I just
you know it's just so real to me it's
like I look at all of you like I joke
Rick like you better be [ __ ]
listening and everybody who's listening
right now you got to just ask yeah you
just gotta ask and you just have to have
something to offer when you're a
youngster like all of you were it's this
like you have nothing to offer but your
[ __ ] grind that's the funny thing
because when people go for a job they're
gonna be like how much are you going to
pay me what are you gonna do from my
future and that's where they've got it
backwards they actually have to say this
is what I can do for you and for that
you should pay me something but for now
I can do this for you allow me to help
you and that's that's like a Miss I'm
telling you I genuinely believe the
people in the top of their crafts are
gonna get people offering them to pay
once people start putting all these
pieces together yeah absolutely look
college 3040 thousand dollars a year
your first business that you start you
can make a two hundred thousand dollar
mistake before you sneeze I don't like
giving people dabs I'm telling you right
now I'd have a tough time saying no to
work for Jeff Bezos for a month for free
right now if you could stand next to
Jeff Bezos I would take that job right
now - I would love to I'd love to see
what the game he plays cuz I need an
hour
hey like I'll do it for a month because
I committed but like and I just wish
more people let's get phone numbers so
like man I'm sorry to stop you in your
story but [ __ ] man
well let me let me say this digital
marketing I didn't know a goddamn thing
about digital marketing two years ago we
go to open rumble III we don't use
digital marketing and catch in a
traditional sense I don't know it's a
cost-per-acquisition I don't know
anything about retargeting all the stuff
you know about Chris who's the guy who
runs all of our digital marketing I meet
him and two months later I am speaking
on a level as good as my friends who run
advertising agencies and I just needed
to be next to him and he needed to learn
about brand
which is what I do the authentic the
real and I need you to learn about what
he did and together that's what made
Rumble super successful but not one
without the other but if I didn't have a
guy like that I'd be structuring culture
that's the way I look at it I'll sing
[ __ ] gray and black and white [ __ ]
data and [ __ ] it's all the same [ __ ]
it's no Union yang imbalance in harmony
that's everybody thinks it's one or the
other and if if he won because he
learned something I won because I
learned something and that's the other
thing people young people need to
realize it has to go both ways
it has to be symbiotic it has to work
it's just you know like you were saying
earlier just like like oh right there's
like you've been hanging out with a
bunch of the people on the team you're
like oh right there's work in between
yeah people are getting confused by
Instagram yeah
they see the [ __ ] blow-up swans in
the rose' and [ __ ] Coachella and they
just think like like most people aren't
trust fund babies that's right and
they're and they forgot because 2007
wasn't too long ago and then 2008 all
those jobs disappeared and people have
to reset I can't wait for it to reset
because then people are gonna get real
jobs again but it's interesting because
now you have all these startups with
these big budgets and they're paying
people this big money that's not gonna
last and people are gonna have to get
real jobs ask everybody where the where
the A&R people are from from 20 years
ago that were with it with an artist 25
deep they're gone the amount of 49 year
olds right now that are executives and
big companies who can tell you at 22 you
know they were worth eight million
dollars on paper is unlimited yeah
people just don't do their history no
there's a very big reason why my report
cards D's and F's except for history
that's funny
it really really matters it matters and
it's it's very interesting to understand
that if you pay attention to the people
that do the work and then the people who
don't do the work the history lesson
will repeat itself and repeat itself and
repeat itself it's super simple I use
Turner's people like philosophy class I
didn't get it now I find philosophy
super interesting because they're the
strategies and the principles of it are
the same super interesting so what's on
your mind these days like like knowing
this is an entrepreneurial audience like
what's like what are you about now like
how are you thinking about you know
you're scaling these two companies yeah
I'm trying to I'm trying to keep it real
quite honest I'm trying to keep it real
and aver
unreal world I'm trying to like I'm
trying to match authentic experiences in
a place where people are trying to do a
lot of unauthentic things you got these
micro influencers and this person and
that person doing all these things and
none of it are real and I'm trying to
just do honest work I'm trying to do
honest work trying to do in a creative
way and it's very hard it's very choice
opening I know that was recent forget
Vegas opening was awesome you know it
was really great and by the way Randy
Gerber who I worked for
15 years ago he he owns Casa amigos
tequila now did fantastically well and
you know from those relationships he did
his opening party with us so he himself
George Clooney Cindy Crawford and that's
a real honor you're 40 years old you
worked for this guy
16 17 years ago and for him that to
throw his event with us big event yeah
it was it was the whole thing it was
thousand people it was they flew in on a
private airplane they did a massive
promotion around it and that's just
priceless and those are the moments
where you pinch yourself for a minute
but you gotta remember like those are
just moments just like every time I've
ever gotten something cool in the press
I don't believe it I'm the really like
oh you're the best thing that ever
happened just like I won't believe it on
the worst thing ever happened I really
try to stick it in the middle because if
you did I I dare you to get one of these
guys in this office to do a New York
Post the hottest next this and go after
12 months and see if it even exists it's
probably a ninety to one of failure to
success so you really I think people if
they're thinking about like keeping
their success going the authentic stay
real honey my brother and I have this
sports agency and I keep telling him the
day you got drafted is the day the work
actually starts everybody thinks it's
like VC funding everybody there's this
great clip of me on the internet where I
was on this like Bloomberg show was
about like funding and every company and
the one company goes we didn't get
funding we just decided to make like a
business and we're getting paid and the
audience is dead silent
I lose my [ __ ] I'm like see this is why
everything's [ __ ] up I didn't see you
know how to be nicer than that yeah I
brought up that story but like that clip
is a Bloomberg like TechStars show
that's what it's from Andy
everyone like everyone celebrates the
wrong [ __ ]
we raised eight million dollars
celebration no [ __ ] you just
gave up a big chunk of your business and
now you have to execute yeah and now
that next race I got drafted I'm like
cool but now you have to actually play
yeah and like almost everybody doesn't
make it and that like that's interesting
I know like page six just said there it
is so like you know one meal at a time
one class at a time host page six saying
you're the hottest you've watched over
20 years that place not around twelve
months later doesn't happen and when you
raise money and that's the other thing
everybody it's get a phone call go ahead
keep going when you raise money and you
think you've done it no you just got
started and now you have a much higher
opportunity of failure than you did fine
voices that's right you gotta answer no
Lamberto you know yeah it's real it's
real it's real it's not real if you do
great if you do great it's all roses yes
this is Gary Vaynerchuk
hey yeah how are you very good say hello
to Eugene hey you see it helps do it man
very well my man nice to meet you how
are you doing well doing well what is
your question my guy so pretty
straightforward I basically started an
event rental company basically doing
like bounce houses tables chairs water
slide slipping slides all the fun stuff
about a year and a half ago
and it really kind of ramped up like it
started is like oh it's just kind of
make a couple extra bucks and now like
we're getting you know pretty close to
six figures so but I've started to get
some competition in the area that has
basically popped up out of nowhere
copying my pricing buying the exact same
like units I have and a copy and you
know all my social media stuff that I'm
throwing out there so I wanted just some
advice on basically you know how to keep
crushing it but also you know not to
really care that that competition is
kind of popping up and copy at
everything I'm doing
dude you're Wes you're [ __ ] set
anytime somebody's copying you you have
the leverage everybody cries I love when
people people only copy me because I
give away all my [ __ ] for free i vlog
all day livestream all day give away all
my advice all day it's mainly because I
want people copying me
if somebody's copying you you [ __ ]
one the problem is you can't rest on
your [ __ ] laurels and if you're
thinking that somebody's copying you is
[ __ ] you up you're starting to rest
my man just gotta make sure you're not a
one-trick you got to make sure you're
not a one-trick pony if you're doing
something and that's the only thing you
can do and some dude follows you
then you're not that serve to lose dick
you know what I mean like that's the
punchline like if you if you're so copy
above all that if somebody copies it
that it [ __ ] up your game you deserve
to lose that's actually how it plays out
elevator die elevator died and and
unless I'll tell you the thing is is
like you know you capture something
right like I mean back to what we were
talking about earlier somebody opens a
big time big restaurant in the
Meatpacking District they're crushing
what do you think happens next
nobody else [ __ ] buys another
building and they open one if that
person starts crying that that happened
they always lose I see this every day
like nothing is ownable I love when
people hit me up on social or email or
DM they're like yo I need to copyright
my idea or I need to trademark my idea
I'm like [ __ ] you think this is
1984 that shit's over
this is about execution there's no
[ __ ] original ideas and oh by the way
bro you didn't [ __ ] invent rentals and
[ __ ] slip and slides either oh
absolutely not
so stop
I think I've seen that this year and we
really got rejuvenated this year to
really start branching into other areas
that know the competition in my area are
going to you know keep it fresh and it
really starts to you know give offerings
that you know hey that's it brand new
fresh to the areas that you know a
they're gonna have to come along and
copy those if they want them tell you
what what runs through my mind success
often leads to complacency right and I
think what you just went through a cycle
of is like when I heard that you just
said we got rejuvenated you got
rejuvenated because competition
rejuvenated you not you rejuvenated
yourself and that's okay but that's a
lesson you need to learn does that make
sense
absolutely and I would just add this I
think about if you think about your
competition you think too much about
them it's like a pickpocket or tapping
you on the shoulder you look to your
left and they're stealing your while to
the right focus on your own wallet focus
on your own stuff and don't allow
yourself to get pickpocketed by some do
tapping you on the shoulders stay
focused on your stuff and like Gary said
don't get distracted stay true to what
you're doing and you're gonna be great
Wes the worst thing going on in my life
right now is that people think I know
who they are right like I mean I'm out
and about right and I'm at the Super
Bowl I'll be in Charlotte for the NBA
all-star I'll go to Eugene's very trendy
places and there's very special people
there and I'm being introduced and
people are starting to know who I am
because of what's happening in my life
and I'm devasting I stress about on
earth right now I spend no time not a
minute knowing what anybody on earth is
doing except my audience responding to
my [ __ ]
thus when I'm out in public and they're
like hey Gary you know Johnny Magoo and
I'm like [ __ ] like clearly everyone
knows who johnny Magoo is I don't want
to come off as like egotistical and dick
so I'm like you know I don't and I don't
want to come off and be like yeah but
then be off inauthentic literally this
is not a joke bro the number one anxiety
I have right now is I almost don't know
who anybody is on earth because I'm
sorry in my own [ __ ] and I'm telling you
right now more people need to do that
because if you're worried about anybody
else
that's a minute
you're taking away from your customer
instead of like looking at them copying
your social call every customer that
you've ever had and say thank you and
ask them if they need anything
absolutely cool do that bro Eugene on
that note let's talk about Rumble for a
minute all right um how is the boxing so
that you know these one thing I'm
curious about how are you thinking about
this you're too smart to not know this
truth right now in America over the last
half decade it's been very clear that
the exercise trends have been popping
and then fading pretty quickly cycles
like have been going fast yeah how do
you think about that when you think
about rumble in the fact that whether
it's Orangetheory or so psych yeah yeah
you know clear I just know you enough
even the mole in mid time you have to be
thinking about like okay how do I build
something that's a marathon run that's
right isn't just playing on this Tran of
fat its iconic that's right I got a do
iconic type [ __ ] you got to do stuff
that is better every single day and day
in and day I will say this now please
sushi has been around for hundreds of
years it used to be in a shitty little
room with a shitty little guy and you
didn't see anything
all of a sudden place like Nobu put some
house music some cool lighting and some
sauces on the stuff and rejuvenates the
brand but the authenticity of sushi was
always there boxing
bottling same [ __ ] it's been around for
hundreds of years African American why
people Irish people rich people poor
people it shifts UFC it goes to
something else it's always gonna be
there and more importantly it's a damn
good time it's a damn good workout and
it works all right I believe you who's
this
Christine Christine Christine is Gary
Vaynerchuk
a mom with Eugene please say hello hey
Gary how are you I'm super well say
hello to Eugene hey Eugene how are you
good how are you what's going on I'm so
stoked you guys call me Gary can I
please fly to New York and buy you lunch
really like lunch takes time
that's me you see let's see how good
your question is my question is okay
listen let me set let me lay this down
I found you Gary on Facebook coupling it
like two years ago you're standing from
a dumpster
Hana Yori about other people's opinions
are trashed yes I can track yes let me
tell you that changed my life Gary you
changed my life with that statement I
just want to thank you because my you
took my life I started my business
eighteen months ago
five oh don't go on Instagram if you
would follow me I would die I'm gonna
follow you around got me hi I'm a little
cuts a little cop logo hole in the
doughnut it's genius right so I started
my little donut shop 18 months ago I'm
grossing over 500k yeah you're firing me
up because because I want I like I like
what's going on Justin's face held on
what 18 months ago I'm and I'll never
forget that I was on a flight I read
something as we were landing that picked
me off like no business I ran off the
plane I was pissed cuz d-roc was taking
a few minutes to get off the plane cuz I
could feel my energy of like my anger
excitement need to talk yeah
fading so like we couldn't wait so I was
like [ __ ] it let's just do it in from
this dumpster oh yeah it's amazing how
truth always wins so you see that video
it changes your mindset and allows you
to start a business is that what
happened yeah because I people I've
owned bakeries in Sarasota for a long
time in Sarasota Florida and I would
like the last caller called in other
people's always starting stuff out of
everybody's copying your business so I
want to do something that would take off
that was [ __ ] light and take off and
that's what I needed that's what I need
for my life and so I saw that video and
there's this guy a comic keyboard
warrior here in town and he was writing
[ __ ] about me online
telling everybody I was a hack and it
pissed me off and so I saw your video
and that was it that was my mindset that
that 18 months is that those people are
trashed but then you've been preaching
lately about listening to your customers
and how important those opinions are
that they're telling you that you're
doing a shitty job so I walk a fine
balance yes the real truth of your
opinion that's exactly the way that is
the contradiction right listen like
they're you know everybody always says
to me like Gary if you you know that
there's
that classic line like if I listen to my
customers I would have made faster
horses and not made a car but then
there's like tone death that's exactly
right it's in that balance but let me
tell you one thing those keyboard
warriors as we like to call them they're
not your [ __ ] customers they're
people that are painful they're people
that are hurting inside
and the only outlet that they understand
is trying to drag somebody into their
misery and you and your exactly and you
know what else they are there are people
that are sitting on the [ __ ]
sidelines because they don't have the
balls to jump at the game yeah but I'll
say don't say this pristine way but I'll
say this one of the reasons why I'm so
happy is I don't have that same level of
anger that you're sitting right now
which I love by the way I love it
because it's a motivator believe it or
not and it's fun to be sipping it and
wait a minute I am a funny feeling you
did not buy empathy wines tell the truth
right now if you lie you will die did
you order empathy wines did I what did
you order
empathy wines did you go to empathy
wines calm and order a subscription do
not lie there's no prayer for lunch nope
but we're gonna start with we're gonna
start with this trade you're gonna go by
a minute you can well I don't like
donuts I do like this but a my heaviest
this morning I dipped it like I got a
[ __ ] it focused I'm fasting today boy
listen to me you need to order empathy
wines I'll give you a follow we'll start
building our relationship slowly what
can we answer for you awesome
so scalable growth franchisee or
company-owned stores I have people
coming at me right and last what offer
what's the name of the company because I
want to make sure everybody hears it
five-o donut Co and Sarasota Florida
five-o donut Co that's [ __ ] fresh
actually I've got outline like talk to
people on the floor whom the doughnut
I've got a mug shot wall with a photo
booth you can come in and take your mug
shot and photo booth and send it out on
your Instagram your Facebook so
basically my customers are creating ads
to me every time they walk in the door
of that little pile in line so how many
and they want one location to location
currently both in Florida yeah I opened
my first location one year I open first
location at the end of May
28:17 in the summer of 2018 a year later
in Mexico location Nick do just followed
you yeah look at my info it's a good
product porn so what what's the debate
between franchising and owner-operator
what are you trying to figure out I'm
just trying to figure out the best way
to scale growth and they both more by
the way they both this is historically
correct they both work it becomes a
self-awareness game of how dope you are
you have to understand how dope you are
or you have to understand whether you
like yeah what you like like I'll be
honest with you like I'm just weirdly
like I'm going from not wanting to have
lunch with you to wanting to be your
business partner like you better stay on
the phone here I'm like I might send
filter Anto might be coming to Florida
to see you Jared can I tell you if you
said you see em I sent you DM saying
Jerry please visit my last time you had
a doughnut no no I I don't haven't
Yoshimi
you eat healthy I'm doing it but when I
go when I am willing to escape yes
there's always baked goods okay like
baked goods are always when I want to
escape and like yeah I had a muffin in
LA like two days ago and it was [ __ ]
amazing I have never seen Gary anything
other than healthy food every single
really good food yes by the way anybody
watching you have to go to catch it's in
every [ __ ] location you don't have to
but if you want to I wanna have a
business meeting with you at catch with
Phil Toronto in the next 60 days 45
minutes me you and Phil Toronto at catch
one objective possibly being our
business partners amazing I'll be down
I'm back you know I got it Gary I'll
send an email right now and I'm going to
buy my wine after I get home from the
grocery store you better that meetings
not gonna happen see ya
alright Eugene the idea like dead people
though in mug shots on the models boxing
you followed you sell I don't have to
make that rule are you g got a few
minutes cuz Tyler getting antsy
I could see him through the mare he
looks and sees dressed what I want to
make sure we get across anything that
you kind of you know you thought about
this like is there anything that is on
your mind anything you want to share
anything no ma'am
look I'm excited to be here I loved I
love working with young people by the
way the two people that used to work at
your office that work here I called you
I said look I need some young hustlers
and I want people with growth and you
and your handing me two guys on that
note I apologize Eugene for everybody
watching if you own a business if you're
running a company one thing I always say
like obviously I always want to keep
everybody however I have you have if you
own a business if you actually want to
bring value to people you have to watch
the people that work for you
there are times when it's I when I look
and it's obvious to me that different
people need different jerseys than the
one they currently have in my place
where I know they can shine plus its
moments in time I'll be very honest with
you both of the guys I'm looking down
them in the face if they came to Boehner
in 2009 it would have been different but
when they
we're in the system at that time through
the serendipity it's [ __ ] serendipity
I think way too many people are selfish
with talent right and then more
importantly like don't realize how the
world works
like this couldn't make me feel better I
agree and I gotta say this is it's hard
to find town so if I'm sitting here
talking about catching rumble they're
both super exciting brands I'm just
creating experiences quite honestly so
when people ask how do I do better than
the next guy I don't know I can buy the
same tuna that you can buy I can buy the
same vodka that you can buy I could buy
the same one that you can buy it's got
to be everything else so it's always the
intangible thing EMP right it's patience
and practicality you have both those
things
look what I have is patience but what I
what I'm challenged by is that I think
every day is my last and I and that is
something from being a kid and that's
the problematic thing and even how
successful you are you always think that
every day is your birthday party and
when I when I walk into catch I think
every day is my birthday party I don't
think anyone's coming so I get up every
morning with that stress on my back and
I try to find that sense of urgency in
young people I cannot I think being
patient and lacking entitlement it's
very easy to balance both you can't have
entitlement in the business that you do
you absolutely have to realize that
customers you can't have entitlement
absolutely well I mean well that's the
singular mistake I see here's what I
realize you walk in to catch I don't
wait for you to come say hello to me if
I'm sitting at the table I jump the [ __ ]
up and I go to you to say hi to your
table and now the people who think they
ever get to an ownership position think
life gets easier I don't understand that
why they think they're gonna have less
problems when they become successful you
work for them I work for everybody I
work for everybody only people I don't
work for my parents cuz they love me no
matter what beyond that like I got to
perform and I got to earn and I know
that I know that going into look I've
had some amazing years in the success of
catch in the success of Romo but we've
had some bad years we've closed some
places I'm not ashamed to talk about
that stuff by the way those failure
those Prouty and they can get real jobs
like I'm I love losing it's part of the
equation you know it's not losing though
it's just it's not real losing but it is
losing except you're willing to learn
from that loss it's missing a business
going out of business is losing yes
right what is this thing is what you're
saying is in the macro it doesn't have
to be the it's not the end
and a lot of times you think it is so
for anybody who's ever lost it's not
real sports right Kobe Bryant Paul
Pierce who I hate
you know um anybody so great on it
anybody who ever anybody any great
athlete in any sport right Mariano
Rivera Darrelle Revis I'll use like
nonetheless whatever ready here's a
sports works you go into the league
right it's completely based on merit if
you're good enough nineteen twenty what
if you're good enough you're good enough
you play your whole career you become a
[ __ ] legend you are a hall-of-famer
you're towards the end of your career
thirty-four young by the way 35 37
nobody on the field cares that you're
going to the Hall of Fame actually let's
use boxing every great boxer pretty much
except for Floyd and a couple of other
people get their [ __ ] ass do you know
who Muhammad oddly lost to Trevor
Berbick Trevor Berbick is the last
person to beat Muhammad Ali beat his ass
not Larry Holmes like everybody thinks
cuz they're not educated Trevor Berbick
beat the [ __ ] out of Muhammad Ali right
you know why cuz in sports you get to
see it happen which is you're only as
good as your last at-bat that's right in
business for some reason back to your
point people get big they had a great
career and for some reason those
[ __ ] think they get to relax
but the market the customer there Trevor
Berbick it wasn't Trevor Berbick job and
I think he went in the Bahamas look it
up I think it was somewhere outside the
US I think it's a Bahamas
it wasn't Trevor Berbick his job in
1982-1983 no no Mike Tyson knocked out
Trevor Berbick Trevor Berbick beat
Muhammad Ali go look at Muhammad Ali's
career look googled Muhammad Ali's last
vesta soom it's a fact it is a [ __ ]
fact it wasn't Trevor Berbick job to go
into that ring and say Muhammad Ali
you're a legend let me lay down for you
he beat his [ __ ] ass right
that's right right because Muhammad Ali
needs to know he needs to get into a
different ring correct to take a
different color no idea why all these
entrepreneurs running around here build
a big business and then think they can
rest on the Laurel because a young lion
is coming to take your [ __ ] that's right
it's fighting people wanting to get
regular jobs they have structure and now
that's like pooh-poohed as a bad thing
but man it's it's hard push yourself
every day get up in the morning and say
if you don't have to be at work at 9:00
a.m. do you go do you go to lunch a
little longer do you hang out a little
longer and then how much money can you
lose in five minutes Andy and I were in
LA on business the other day and after a
meeting that lasted 20 minutes which I
dictated 19 of the other crew went to
lunch for an hour and a half and we went
back to our car next meeting and I was
making fun of it and Andy just lives
right here and it was like funny like he
was like yeah I don't even know what the
real world looks like like that's
exactly right I LA by the way is a
meeting pre lunch and a meeting post
lunch and that's about it and that's the
two meanings in the day and lunch in
between to break it up before you end
the day and that's that's the LA life
but again entrepreneurship has the sexy
vocabulary too it goes beau do it ever
so do us and here isn't the last line of
the fence last line everyone sucks
there's nobody else to have great
partners that's what I would say to
anybody have great partners what's your
question of the day I wrote it down I'm
gonna mess it up what's the one business
you believe could be elevated by an
experienced something wax something that
needs to be disrupted what what's
something that people do every single
day that needs to be disrupted I want to
know because I want to do it I love
appreciate thank you so much for time
great to see all you young people make
me look old and feel old y'all got great
hair by the way really thanks for being
out do you appreciate it let's keep
watching hey guys thank you so much for
watching my video on YouTube I wanted to
jump in here at the end because I'm
working on a ridiculously important
project for me and I have a funny
feeling you can help if you drink wine
at all or know anybody that drinks wine
at all please go to empathy wines calm
right now and sign up for a subscription
whether it's a three pack whether it's a
six pack or whether it's a whole case of
each for the year
if you drink 36 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of
a year please sign up for club empathy
this project means the world to me I
could really use your support
[Music]